hey what is up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
this is a 2013 Nexus 7 it's the first
device to ship with Android 4.3 out of
the box so it's 4.3 really that much
better than 4.2 well I made a video not
too long ago about how Google is taking
back Android and really moving a lot of
the major feature updates to the Play
Store rather than an operating system
updates so that leaves a lot of people
thinking that Android 4.3 must just be
this super minor update mostly under the
hood improvements but an improvement is
still an improvement so that any further
ado let's go ahead and take a look at
the top 5 improvements from what I've
been using in Android 4.3 jelly bean
number 5 is that Google Play games comes
pre-installed in Android 4.3 so you
don't have to go to the Play Store and
find it so Play games is actually new to
Android I went over a little bit more of
it in depth in my Google i/o recap from
this year which is when it was first
introduced but aside from all the fancy
leaderboards and challenges in
side-by-side friend gameplay it has app
data sync across devices hooked up into
it which means you can get to a certain
level on your phone of a game and then
pick up your tablet and have the same
game installed and continue from where
you left off so as long as you sign into
your Google account on both which you
probably are you can get to level 30 in
Angry Birds and then pick up your tablet
and start level 31 without a hitch which
is pretty sweet
number 4 is Bluetooth and Wi-Fi
improvements now a lot of these seem
like behind the scenes changes but again
connectivity is really important for
these Wi-Fi only tablets in the
Bluetooth Department you're going to
have the ability to connect to bluetooth
low energy devices so Bluetooth smart
all you know little peripherals like
wearable tech you know the fitness bands
and the smartwatches and things like
that that it's kind of a misnomer saying
Bluetooth Low Energy as it doesn't
actually refer to the amount of energy
consumed by using the technology but it
refers to the type of devices that you
can connect to using the technology but
allowed it again wearable tech like
Google glass as a matter of fact
actually use this so it's nice that it's
included now and in the Wi-Fi department
you actually get this always-on
low-power Wi-Fi state because Wi-Fi is a
much better more accurate way of telling
location rather than firing up those big
energy taking GPS radios so you can
actually leave always-on Wi-Fi on in the
background to give a rough locate
which saves a lot of power number three
is restricted profiles now Android 4.2
gave you the ability to have multiple
accounts on a single Android tablet
which was nice because you could just
switch between them very seamlessly on
the lockscreen Android 4.3 gives you the
ability to control a lot more of what
that other account gets to see in terms
of data in terms of images and video and
stuff in your gallery and basically all
the applications that are involved so
you can cut off a whole bunch of
different applications from a guest
account being able to see that's kind of
nice if you like to show your tablet to
your friends or share a tablet with
other people I probably won't be using
this all that much because I'm the only
one who uses my tablet but if you happen
to be sharing with a lot of different
people this is a very useful feature
number two is behind the scenes
improvements specifically in the
graphics department a lot of what makes
Android 4.3 actually feel faster and
smoother than Android 4.2 is in the
graphics which makes sense because
that's what you're looking at in Android
4.3 now supports opengl 3.0 which brings
much improved graphics performance
optimization and overall butter
rendering tweak spring improved
performance throughout android it's all
kinds of things that go on behind the
scenes that you may not think sound like
a big update to Android but trust me
they are welcome in the performance
boost you end up seeing when actually
using a device with Android 4.3 and
number one again comes in the
performance Department in what we'll
call trim TR i.m trim is essentially a
technology that keeps the on-board
storage clean from garbage build up and
in Nexus devices onboard storage is
everything right now every time you
install a new app or add something to
your Nexus 7 it creates a data point and
in order to keep track of all these
different data points and clusters your
operating system basically creates a
mapping index across all these different
data points to keep track of where to
access everything and where everything
is the problem is that without trim
there is no way to clean up that index
if you were to delete an app or a song
or a file or a document which makes the
index very garbagey very cluttered and
and not clear and rough and incomplete
and tied up and just just garbage but
Android 4.3 enables trim basically
system-wide which enables the operating
system to tell when data points are no
longer needed and can be deleted from
the end
he races all the garbage and ends up
leaving your device's feeling newer and
faster and more responsive again access
times are going to be a lot quicker
which essentially means that if you have
that old Nexus 7 that's slowing down and
feeling really slow
grab that 4.3 update and it's like
getting a new tablet so there it is
under the hood improvements and minor OS
updates actually contribute a lot to how
much Android has grown in the past
couple years if we didn't get those
minor updates we'd still be back in the
days of gingerbread or Froyo
either way that's been it thank you for
watching if you enjoyed this video feel
free to give a thumbs up and if you want
to see more videos like this or if
you're excited for the full Nexus 7
review and all the coverage I have for
that definitely subscribe because that
is coming up very soon either way like I
said thanks for watching and I'll talk
to you guys in the next video